oui on l'a entendu il ne s'agit pas d'un
taudis mai à l'occasion de ce drame on
s'interroge à nouveau sur ces hôtels
meublés dont certains sont très vétustes
on parle souvent des fermé mais
l'obstacle est toujours le même il
faudrait reloger les occupants caroline
gauthier christophe la roque à un hôtel
meublé insalubre comme il en existe des
dizaines dans le centre ville de
marseille
ici trente deux locataires s'entassent
et marocains des tunisiens des algériens
tous en situation régulière
ces personnes vivent dans l'insécurité
ils ont souvent peur de recevoir des
planchers ou de passer au travers
souvent les installations électriques
sans plus que dangereuse qu'on vous riez
fait il n'y a pas de gain à n'ont plus
d'eau chaude ni de chauffage des murs
qui soit d'humidité et ce pour 100 à 300
euros par mois et par personne
yeah yeah ya pas chauffée à blanc par
ailleurs nos shows la ville n'a t elle
pas la plupart de ses hôtels sont
frappés d'arrêtés de fermeture mais peu
importe les marchands de sommeil
encaisse toujours les loyers aux
analphabètes et isoler leurs locataires
se laisse piéger supportons lucie - du
ventoux but fantôme lui aujourd'hui la
mairie de marseille réhabilite ses
hôtels mais qui dit réhabilitation dit
aussi changement de population à coups
de menaces les pauvres sont chassés par
les marchands de sommeil
pour preuve ce document émis par la
société marseille aménagement en
dernière page cette phrase
le fonds devra être libéré de ses
occupants alors seulement
l'hôtel est vendu les locataires se
retrouvent sans toit ce sont les jambes
comme profité d'être des marchands de
sommeil pendant des années les années
qu'il doive horloger c'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas les moyens de rollon génie
la volonté il faut que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités conséquence ces immigrés
n'ont d'autre solution que de changer de
rues ou de quartiers et là ils se
retrouvent entre les mains d'un autre
marchand de sommeil